All right.
So here's the recordings.
I'm doing this on my iPhone before
I go to the airport. And yeah,
I realize they fucked up and I,
I recorded that thing in mono.
I didn't realize it. My, uh, Andrew Andrew
realized itself, so sorry about that.
I fucked up again. Anyways, I do want to
thank everybody for all the donations.
Um, if you haven't already
heard, we were almost at $10,000.
Uh, we raised for, uh, those,
uh, sick children I was
telling you about on Monday.
We did it in just three days.
Uh,
you guys came through in a huge way and a,
you really left some great
messages and you know what, you,
you changed some great
people's lives for the better.
So thank you very much.
Um,
I can't believe I had a podcast for this
long and I've never done anything like
that. I'm serious. Who Manage,
even if you donated just a dollar,
um, you know, you helped
some people not be homeless.
There was another family that didn't
have, you know, a hot water heater.
They had no hot water and they're dealing
with their kid who has bone marrow
cancer. So, uh, um, thank
you. So anyways, with that,
let's get onto the um, the, uh,
advertising advertising's
advertisements. Oh, Sherry's berries.
Look who's back. The old horseback
in town. Uh, it's that time again,
Christmas time,
which equals Christmas shopping.
You can always tell if you pick the right
gift by the look on their face talk.
Well shit, I eat chocolate
covered berries, kind of
look to you going to get, um,
it's gotta be one or the other. Like
what the fuck are Goddamn. Thank you.
Talk about when you've given,
I'll shut up.
What you need is a site where you can
check everyone off your list and f and a
find a gift they're going to love. And
it's all online. No mail, no parking wars,
no lines. What I'm talking
about is Sherry's berries.
Every gift from them is an instant
hit. Get Sherry's berries, sweet,
freshly dipped strawberry
starting at just 1999.
That's a 40% savings.
These Gore made Barry's core made berries.
You pick them up a fucking
tree like everybody else.
I think from the ground
anyways, they're fresh, juicy,
and dipped in dark white and milk
chocolate deliciousness. They,
they're sprinkled with decadent toppings
like chocolate chips and chopped nuts.
I'm not gonna lie to you. I've actually
eaten them. They're fucking delicious. Uh,
I just like made fun of them anyways,
so you can double the berries for
just $10 more. To get this deal,
you have to go to Barry's dot com
and use my special code Burb B, u r.
R. A. These dipped and decorated berries
make both a thoughtful and a delicious,
enjoyable gift. It's not really
thoughtful. It's fucking easy.
You're selling convenience here,
Sherry. Oh, isn't that thoughtful?
He went to a website and press enter
or return, whatever the fuck you do.
Sherry's berries has a holiday gift that
will bring joy to everyone in your list.
And there's more than just berries.
Snowmen Brownie pops shaped like the
snub and stick a chocolate dip pigment.
Yeah. Yet asked sex with a
woman snowman, chocolate dip,
peppermint cookies and
cheesecake bites and lots more.
They will deliver all your gifts fresh
to your dorm on the date you choose.
Here's the only way to get these,
this amazing offer.
Sherry's berries starting in
1999 visit berries.com. B, e.
R. R. I. E. S.
You Click on the microphone at the top
right hand corner and you'd type in
Berbee, R, R, B, B, u, r,
r. Go to Barry's dot com.
Click on the microphone and type in
birth. Order them today. A right.
Hey, what's going on? It's bill burr
and it's time for the Thursday after
the new, just before Friday,
Monday morning podcasts
and
just checking in on Yaas your week going,
how's your holiday fucking season by and
fucking gifts for a bunch of where most
of the year you don't even like
him. Um, I did some more Christmas.
I did some more Christmas shopping today.
I think I pretty much got it done.
Um, as far as my wife, I'm
done with that shit. You know,
I got enough shit to put on it.
I got the one main gift.
Then you have enough other shit to fill
up the fucking area under the tree.
It's so stupid.
Um,
I got to get her like one more
thing and um, and then that's it.
But other than that, I'm getting
ready to go back east. Uh,
I got to do some press here to
hype. F is for family. What is that?
You might ask if you've
been under a fucking rock,
not listening to my podcast for the last,
I don't know how year it's coming out.
December 18th six motherfucking episodes
on Netflix. You can watch all six.
It took me four years
to go through this whole journey and you
can devour all of it and to two hours
and 40, 45 minutes maybe. And
then you could send me a tweet.
What's an extra six coming out? Hopefully
within a year or maybe a little more.
Who knows who the fuck knows?
Who knows if enough people watch
it and get a second season.
I don't know what that means.
10 12 I have no idea.
Which is why if you go to my website,
I only have one date for next year
because I have to see if this thing,
you know, tanks, if it makes it
a what, you know, what are you,
what are you gonna do, you know,
this guy's looking this way,
that guys are going that way and this
gaze, they, what do you want from me?
So anyways,
I'm sitting here in the end,
the DFT finally finished basement of
my fucking house and I am on my second
attempt at smoking ribs and the big
green egg is going down right now.
And uh,
so I am almost an hour and 55 minutes
into a four hour smoke on these things.
My temperature is still right at two 50.
It got a little high in the,
in the first hour.
I get impatient before I lock it in
and it went up as high as three, three,
10 and uh,
it stayed there for a good 10,
15 minutes and I was able to bring it
down to two 74. While now I'm at two 50.
So I don't know what
they're going to taste like,
but I'm already doing better
than I did the last, uh,
the last time I tried this,
my fire went out in an hour and a half,
so an hour and a 55 minutes in.
I'm still at two 50,
so I went a little too high.
But you know what's killing me is I,
it's not smoking anymore. And the
way the big green egg is, is set up.
I can't like open it up and do
all of that shit. It's not as,
I should just get a fucking smoker,
but it was smoking like a motherfucker.
Yeah,
no,
it's fucked.
Okay. You're old freckles up.
Just [inaudible] a boy. Yeah.
He came down every gay one thing or
smoke rib thought he could do and she,
you gotta be, you gotta be born down here.
You gotta be born in the swamp, right?
Your mother put on her back,
maybe face down in that fucking swamp.
Impregnating and you come out the same
stank hole and, uh, that, you know,
I smoke yourself some ribs.
Um, yes, I am a novice and,
um, I was disgusting and everything
I Just said was absolutely disgusting
considering I'm talking about food,
you know,
and the fact that it's so close to
mother's Day, you know what I mean?
Okay.
That's right. It's only
five months away. Um,
so I dunno what happens this time I had,
I had the blocks of Victor Hickory and
that I also soaked a bunch of chips and I
thought I put a zillion of
them in there and uh, it will,
they'll look at fucking house fire
for the first 40 minutes and then,
and now just nothing. So,
um, I don't know what to do.
I'm thinking to open it up and throw
in some more chips in there. Uh,
I don't know how I'm going to do
it cause I got the plates center.
I don't fucking know.
But they,
okay.
I Dunno who the fuck knows. You know
what it is the worst case scenario.
I just fuck up a rack of ribs,
you know, worst case scenario,
fucking pig died for nothing. Well not
for nothing, just one side of it's ribs.
I don't want,
I'm talking about I believe it or not
actually have the Celtics game on in the
background.
I thought for some reason it was
Thursday and the Bruins and playing the
Canadians and uh, I went on the center
ice thing and there was nothing on there.
And then I checked ESPN and Lo and behold,
the Boston Celtics have played the Chicago
Bulls and I got to tell you something.
I don't know the name of one
player on the Boston Celtics.
Ah, right. The Guy, he's got the ball,
he's going in towards the painted area.
The shot guy,
a white guy and he kicked it
back out to the black guy.
Fucking mess.
Blow the whistle.
So many white guys on the
court, Jesus Christ. Oh,
there's a guy with the fucking pony tail
who a rip the arm out of the cavalier.
Got He ripped his fucking elbow up.
There you go.
The black guy behind his back end.
The white guy files him cause what
else is he going to do? Stop illegally.
Okay.
White guy walks back to the bed,
shaking his head as if he's not used to.
That happening.
Takes off his lance Armstrong glasses and
sits down on the bench and now a black
was a high top fade was sorta dread
starting, but not sure really.
He goes in for the Waco white gay
shaking his head, no. Is he going?
He's going back to Europe.
He knows it.
He knows that he can already
taste that fucking Romanian hero.
He's going to be eating dinner
another fucking month. Ah, right now,
another black guys got the bar
or left hand on the right hand.
A black guy with dreads looking like a
quarterback, but he's playing basketball.
The black eye goes to the paint.
There's a white guy,
he does not let me file some of course,
and then acts like he didn't do anything.
The big white guy with the ponytail,
he still has his arms over his
head as if he didn't do it.
He wanted to charge better.
I'm sorry. I like college.
Super fucking pro hoops. A way
too long. See, here's the replay.
That's the guy comes in. Yeah,
dude, you're completely fouled them.
You fucking dope. You
jumped right into them. Um,
so anyways, I got to fucking
travel and uh, promote this thing.
I'm going to be true this week. If you're
in New York City, I will be trying to,
uh, do some stand up in
and around the city and uh,
I will be doing the oop,
oop and Jimmy show among some other things
and I'll try to keep you guys posted.
Everything's getting
filled in right now and uh,
I'm site to get back there during the
holiday season, you know what I mean?
Get back there and walked down
fifth avenue, you know what I mean?
Go by Rockefeller Center. Go,
hey, you want to go skating?
And then you see that fucking line that's
like nine miles long and you're like,
hey,
you want to just not do that?
You want to just start fucking drinking
instead. Um, oh, by the way, I did,
I mentioned I'm recording
this on a Wednesday. I didn't
think I told you there.
I said, you're probably wondering why
I'm watching a fucking Celtics game. Um,
but, uh, you know, I realize I
have nothing to fucking talk about.
I have absolutely nothing to talk
about and I am only seven minutes said,
this is, this is what it's like
the bomb on stage people, you know,
when you just fucking burn through your
entire act for seven minutes and you got
to do a half hour,
you're like,
now what the fuck now at the fuck am I
going to talk about when I read a text
here. I mean it was like, oh
Jesus Christ, he's fucking,
you just ain't never fucking
it. You don't, I'm trying to,
I'm trying to do what I have
a flight tomorrow, you know,
and I always wait to
the last second to pack.
I wait to the last second to
do the podcast to do the mail.
I wait for the entire morning,
see tire fucking morning.
I'm running around like an
asshole and right as I sit down,
it's time to go to the airport.
So I decided that this was going to be
the first time that I was going to behave
like my wife and be
totally fucking prepared.
I'm going to have all or any banking I
got to do, done my Christmas shopping,
done I fucking mail done
podcast, done packing, done.
Uh,
but I fucked up cause I decided to smoke
some ribs in the middle of the fucking
thing, which was dumb. But
I'm, all I gotta do is this.
And then I got a pack and
then I'm fucking done.
So, uh, you know what that means then
I gotta I gotta start drinking. Right.
They'll tell you guys,
my wife bought me one.
Those little fucking rubber looks like
a tennis balls and you fill it up with
water and makes those
round fucking ice cubes.
Like that guy from that movie where they,
they,
the black guys robbed the bank and uh,
Terrence Howard,
the fuck was the name of that movie,
not clockers dead presidents.
That was a great fucking movie, wasn't
it? That was a really good movie. I will,
that was that that day she was brothers.
You know what kills me?
That movie seemed like it came out
six years ago to me. And now I'm,
when I'm thinking about that, was that
20 years ago or 20 years ago? Tomorrow.
Not Tomorrow. Next year. Yeah. 96,
no, 95, 95. I moved down to
New York City and I remember,
uh, that Halloween everyone
was, was going out as those,
the people from that movie putting
a white shit on their face.
You know what I mean? Black people
were not white people, you know,
hey, actually, you know,
when you look about black people were
actually going out and white face.
You know,
Donald Trump was kind of go
fucking complain about that. Um,
I did. Uh, oh, not too, I got
to, this is why I have nothing
to talk about. I already,
I did Kevin and being this morning and
then I did fucking Mark Marin's what the
fuck podcast WTF over,
uh,
over his way and uh, promoting theF is
for family thing. I'm sorry, go ahead.
I just said fucking pause right now.
Should I just hit pause and just fucking
tank this entire podcast? I can't,
I have to keep fucking going.
What the Hell is my laptop?
Is there anything to look up
the fuck did I do with my law?
How do you lose a laptop?
I just had the fucking thing.
I swear to God, if I ever
get Alzheimer's, I'm not,
I'm not even going to fucking notice
the affiliate a different, no,
I don't grab my keys. All right,
here we go. Let's open up here.
Let's get on you. Let's see if there's
anything on the fucking, you know what?
I'm literally going to hit pause. I
look up a few things, so this is just,
this is not even,
this is not even a podcast.
This is just listening
to somebody babbling.
You don't like you sitting
in the fucking waiting room,
something you don't want to go. Yeah, but
we know. Go look something up. All right.
Hang on a second. Hang on. All
right, I'm back. Sorry about that.
I apologize for the first 10 and a
half minutes to this fucking thing.
White Guy with the fucking left
hand floater does not go in.
Maybe this is why I don't watch Hulu,
but it just, it makes you feel bad.
You know what I mean?
Okay.
Is a white dude
over the white guy off the glass
and then it's fucking unbelievable.
And he's wearing one of those fucking
windshield masks, you know what I mean?
Like he wanted to be an ax murderer,
but he couldn't commit to it. You know,
he wants to get caught. I forgot
that. I actually, I saw a movie.
I saw a fucking face.
Yeah.
Starring Brad Pitt, uh, Steve Carell,
the guy from drive. What is his fucking
name? He's in everything. Jake. Jaylen.
Oh,
is it Jake Gyllenhaal Miley Cyrus.
Wait a minute.
Wait a minute. I just saw the
fucking movie. You know what it was?
I didn't know it was him. He dyed
his hair and, and a Christian Bale.
I saw that movie, the big short. And, uh,
okay.
A buddy of mine got a screener of it and,
um,
I was watching it with my wife and,
uh,
she kept voice spring over to me.
Go and try to explain this.
You're going to explain this. I don't
know what it was basically about the, uh,
all the shit that led up to the,
uh,
okay.
The big fucking what I would've fucked,
whatever the fuck happened in
2007 it was called the big short,
who is basically these
guys bet against the banks.
They basically bet that what was going
to happen in 2007 was going to happen.
They did it in like 2005 and
all the bankers would just like,
what are you out of your fucking mind?
That could never happen. You know,
that's basically what it is. And
um, I actually, by watching it,
I ended up having a great
conversation with my wife, um,
about that.
Cause I remember when that whole housing
markets scandals and all that fucking
subprime shit happened.
Um,
there was like two schools,
there was either people that 100% blame.
The bankers are people 100% blaming
the fucking jerk off set. Got Houses,
you know, like I remember this,
the guy live like below me, right?
This old fucking crazy guy,
he blamed people,
didn't have any money that got houses.
Like he was flipping,
I called those people,
had no business tech knows houses there,
had no business getting those loans. And I
was just like, well yeah, that's, that's,
that's kind of what you have
a loan officer for, isn't it?
I mean anybody could walk into a bank
and be like, could I have $1 million?
Right. You're, you're totally within
your right to fucking do it. He just,
you don't give it to them.
Yeah,
you're fucking do a little bit of
research. But I, I'm one of those,
I don't have any sympathy for the
bankers or for the fucking jerk offs to
fucking bought like a,
a four bedroom house in their mortgage
was like 80 bucks and they didn't read
the fine print that like,
you know, within whatever,
seven months it was that good one crease
up to like fucking eight grand a month
or something. Nuts. And they look, well
what happened? I'm shit out of luck. Yeah,
you're a fucking dope.
You know why I say that?
Because I flunked everything in fucking
pretty much everything in high school.
I sucked it fucking math.
I had to go to summer school.
Like I should've gone every single year.
I went after my freshman year
and I went after my junior year,
my sophomore year,
my teacher hooked me up and gave
me the d minus in my senior year.
I didn't give a fuck cause I
already screwed up for three years.
Was I going to go to summer
school and get into Brown?
It wasn't happening at that point.
I was actually getting into construction,
you know,
I don't even know why.
Cause I knew I was going to have to
get a fucking job and I didn't want to
really have a boss.
Like I never wanted to have a job with
like the boss was like fucking right
there. Or I had a place to be
like, sit right here at your desk.
You, you, you come in here by eight 30
and you stay put until lunchtime. Right.
And then you'd come back,
you'd better be there by fucking whatever.
What time is lunch? One to two, two a
one. The guy's fucking coming around.
I didn't like that. So I always try. I
worked in a little bit in construction.
I worked in warehousing. You know, he just
had to be a general giant fucking area.
You now there's places to hide.
Not like I didn't do the job, I just
didn't like people fucking, you know, I,
I don't, I don't like people telling
me what the fuck do you know? So, um,
anyways, yeah. So by my senior year I was
like, I, you know, I don't give a fuck,
but I sucked at math and I
was able to figure out, um,
mortgages enough to at least figure out
how I was getting fucked and to reduce
the fuck over as much as I
could. And, um, the first time I,
I went and I bought, I bought
a, I bought a, that was it,
a fucking 83 Ford ranger
for like three grand.
I had like 500 bucks to my name or
something. So I take all 500 bucks.
I put it down in the fucking
car or something like that.
I can't remember the numbers.
And I took out a three year loan and I,
it took me all three years,
you know,
I had like 36 payments and
it took me 36 payments.
I made all of them on time and the bank
got 100% of the amount of interest that
they wanted to get off a dope like me,
the entire three years
that I had the car loan,
it never dawned on me to maybe not go
out drink and fucking a bunch of beers at
night and actually take it some of that
money and throwing it at the principal
of the loan. I didn't know that you
could fucking do that. I had no idea.
And I ended up paying a ton
of fucking money in interest.
So fortunately somebody talked
to me about it. You know,
when I went to going to get a mortgage
and I still fucked up when I first got a
mortgage,
I bought an apartment in New York and uh,
I bought something that I
could afford and I could,
if I could afford the mortgage payment
plus a little bit more. So what?
So the very first
payment,
I made the mortgage payment
plus a little bit more.
But the thing was I
didn't put it in on the,
I didn't fill in the right area on the
mortgage statement where it says, uh,
uh, basically mortgage and
then it says principal.
I didn't know that the principal
was the actual like whatever,
say I want a hundred grant,
you know,
I didn't know that that was called
the principal. I had no fucking idea.
So I kept putting everything into the
mortgage. So within like four months,
you know, all of a sudden I didn't
get, I didn't get a statement
for the fifth month. So I was
like, what the fuck? What the fuck?
I'm calling the bank. Oh, I knew
I didn't get a statement. Oh,
it's good on what's the color?
And they were like, oh, you're,
you're a month ahead on your payments.
Okay.
And I go, what do you mean I'm a month
ahead. I still get like a hundred grand.
It's like, no, blah, blah,
blah. And by them talking to
me, I realized, I went back,
look at the statements.
I'm like, wait a minute,
I've been paying like an extra 400 bucks.
Okay
a month here. And none of it has
come off the principals cause I do.
I wasn't putting that towards the
principal and that's when I figured out,
oh Ah,
this is what I want to fucking do.
I want to pay the mortgage
and then take the other money.
You put it at the fucking principle.
Now a lot of you are
rolling your fucking eyes,
but the amount of people that
go in and get a fucking house,
it never realize that,
okay,
okay.
Oh realize that they did they front
end load the fucking interests.
Like even I think, I think,
isn't it like if you, if you, uh,
even if you're 10 years into
your mortgage, at that point,
you've already given the bag 80% interest,
80% of the interests that they're going
to earn on the money that they loaned
you. Because basically when you buy a
house, if you take 30 years to pay it off,
whenever you took out, you're going to
give the bank two and a half times that.
So just to make it easy be
took out to a hundred grand.
You're going to pay back
$250,000 all right. Now
for as much as the banks are not fucking
regulated for as much as they got the
fucking houses back and they're going
to do it all over again, you know,
make complete fucking shitheads
qualified for mortgages,
right? As long as you, if everybody,
if they could just educate everybody
to that stuff, that whole fucking game,
then people wouldn't get suckered into
those things and then banks could try to
do whatever the fuck they want it to
do. Listen, if you're a dope like me,
if you get a fucking mortgage like it,
but isn't there a lawyer
there to walk you through it?
I remember when I closed, I had a
lawyer, right? He said I did in New York.
Okay.
I don't fucking look.
All I'm saying is watch that movie and
then don't get all freaked while you
should get freaked out because
there's a bunch of mouse.
Breathe in fucking morons out there.
Okay.
Ah, Christ. Why did I watch that movie?
It's so fucking depressing. Like,
but what am I gonna do?
Am My tells 50 people are going to
do what I'm going to say right now.
Okay.
Nobody gives a fuck. Right?
He'll go on, you know,
I'd go out and put $50 down on $1 million
house and enjoy it and do some cannon
balls into the fucking tool before
they throw you out in eight months.
That's what everybody's
going to be doing again.
Do I ever had anything optimistic
to say about the future?
It's really ridiculous.
You would, you would,
you would think during this time a year,
the holiday season that I would
think some shit like that. But um,
for whatever reason I don't.
Um,
that was one thing that it got out
of that and that movie, by the way,
is fucking phenomenal. Steve
Corral is, is amazing. Uh,
the dude from drive,
why can't I remember his fucking name?
I think he's obviously phenomenal.
Act. What the is wrong with me.
All right. Brad Pitt. I'll get three
and a four year and a Christian Bale.
All amazing. The whole
thing is great. And, uh,
I guess I'm depressed after watching
it because in the, you know,
you know the deal, you know, whenever
you fucking watch something like that,
I don't want to ruin the end of the blue.
But she,
you know how those fucking
movies in those kinds of movies,
movies that are deemed a powerful, you
know, what do they predict? They always,
you know, if they did and made a
movie about fucking those dolphins,
getting to fucking shit kicked out of
him over in Japan. I never watched that.
I didn't watch that fucking thing
cause I didn't want to watch a bunch of
dolphins getting beaten to death.
It's just like,
can you just tell me the address I need
to send the money to so the opportunists
can keep most of it in and get in fucking
buy a yacht that he calls the dolphin
or some shit. And then maybe a
couple of it goes to a porpoise.
A couple of bucks goes over there. Can
you just tell me what the fuck that is?
Do I really have to watch the footage?
You know,
the horror of that. Can you just fucking
tell me that's what they do and I'll,
I'll, I'll be fine. Do you ever see like
the trailer for that fucking Oh yeah.
You know, all these fucking people that
love watching gory movies, you know,
saw it's fucking Frankenstein and
Friday the third Tate's and fuck it,
Jason goes to Freddy's camp versus the
Predator or whatever the fuck it's called.
You know, all you gotta do if you
really want to see, fuck. You know,
if that's not enough for you.
Cause I would think if you're
watching a horror films,
it's gotta be like porn
off, right? Where at first,
the first time you watch a porn for
the first time you see a, you see it,
you're like, oh my God. And then that's
it. It's over. It's over like 30 seconds.
You might as well just spending like
in a peep show or just hand crank and a
fucking of view master.
Yeah, you'd be fine.
Be Somehow take it to your head so you
can hand crank it while fucking Yank and
you're fucking the ball
joint down there. Right. Um,
okay.
Did after a while, you know, it's,
you build up a little stamina like
cardio because at the jerk it off,
you know what I mean?
So I would think,
I would think that watching a horror
movies would be the same thing.
Like when you were a kid, you'd watch, uh,
I don't know what the fuck you'd watch.
You'd watch big bird fucking, uh,
try to walk out. He hit himself
on that Chin up bar and that,
that made you feel bad for birds.
I don't fight.
I'm trying to think of I'll lame
horror movie. What's a bad one?
I don't fucking know.
Whatever where they would like the fifth
installment of the killer bees number
that,
and they went all over that guy's Vw
bug and he drove into the super dome and
they turned on the air conditioner
and then they all died.
It's kind of ironic that they're all
dying now because it's getting too hot.
Right. Um, once again, bill,
going back to fucking dude's Day gold
back to doomsday, just shut the fuck up.
Just enjoy, enjoy the
holidays. Um, oh, by the way,
that the pipe Piper's video
should be out any day. Uh,
I'm going to talk to Andrew tonight and
I figured out exactly when that's coming
out. I know he put out
the fucking tray. Um,
can you guys will get to
see my ugly ass kitchen? Uh,
if you wondering what those cupboards
are, it's called knotty pine. Not Naughty,
not like it's bad, bad pine. It
doesn't mean that it's naughty,
like it has knots in it.
And evidently that was all the rage at
some point in the late eighties and early
nineties. But uh, it has
since fallen out of favor,
much like a z cavalry cheese
and fingerless gloves.
But my kitchen is a, my kitchen
is an old modge. Aw, Jesus Christ.
That guy fell on his fucking ass and
he shook it off. Good man. Black Guy,
black guy with the ball. Good deal.
Good deal. He's just Celtic. He's black.
He's got the ball. I liked this. Don't
pass the white guy. Tall. Pass it off.
Eddie messed it. They must of course
he fucking missed it. Of course he did.
Okay.
The Fun. I mean, you know what I mean?
Jesus fucking credit. Yeah. Right there.
Right there. Right down the other end.
The court? Yes. Chicago just scored
Chicago. Just go there to have their,
a prob known who to pass too.
I'm like literally reverse racist when I
watched shoot now the white guy give it
to the white guy again. Do you know one?
Oh, well, so my were up by eight though.
Yeah.
I'm going to shut the fuck up then.
Maybe.
And maybe my white guys
are doing all right.
Okay.
This has to be our second team in there.
Yeah.
All right.
A white guy just faked out another white
guy and then took a shot at the top of
the kid.
Didn't go with it.
Okay.
Is this like a charity game?
I've never seen so many white guys out
on a fucking court and basketball is,
this should be like black and white.
Yeah.
You know what the dribbling with
the hand on top of the ball. Ooh.
Um, was it talking about, oh,
it's talking about the end of the world
jerking off and fucking horror movies.
Um, okay. Yeah, I was going to
say, if you really want to see, uh,
okay.
Yeah. If you want to see something
terrifying. Yeah, I would just watch,
just turn on the nature
channel. What else? Fucking
channel it is. Do you remember,
remember these discoveries to fucking
sit there talking about, you know,
they always talking about
the, uh, the animals, right?
And all of a sudden they're not talking
about animals anymore. Isn't that weird?
That was their whole bread and butter.
That's all they talked about was animals.
Hey, today we're doing the
cheetahs. It's fucking big cat week.
They got that coming up, but
it was dead. It was all it was,
was about pretty much nature, nature.
Right? That's all it was about.
But you know, it was, I mean, I'm gonna
base it on, on a guy, somebody like me.
I stopped watching that fucking
channel because I love animals.
Right?
And the first fucking three quarters
of every one of those episodes was
tremendous. And then the last
third would be like, you know,
this is what they would all be adorable.
Look what they do. Look at them,
their natural habitat.
They do the damn dishes.
Things I'll look at just killed another
animal. That's how they survive.
That's fucking amazing.
And then in the end it was just like
an a and then man came and fucking
completely screwed up
their entire environment.
And then you'd sadly watched them dying
next to an empty fucking plastic milk
carton.
You know what I mean?
Container
does carton say that it's cardboard,
one of the giant gallon. Thanks.
You know what I mean? That's
plastic fucker. Thanks. Right.
Well you never had milk before.
Fucking look at me like that.
They'll look at your car radio
like that. You asshole. Um,
so I kinda stopped watching it but if
people stop watching it because we came to
fucking depressing because at this point
they used to just do shit about bees.
You know, in the human interaction be
some guy would put bees on his face,
right and have a beard.
He have a bee beard right now they're
going to talk about how they're dying off
in an a photosynthesis. Does it
happen? I was like, no more potatoes.
I Dunno.
Wants to watch that.
Yeah.
My favorite thing now is that people
still go in the fucking ocean and there's
no fish left in.
There's more and more shark attacks,
and I think it's going to continue. When
you watch how they vilified the sharks,
you know, those somehow connect
them to isis. You know what I mean?
It's just going to be going to become all
of that. Hey, when the sharks die off,
are we going to make manmade once?
I think that's what's going to happen
in the future because if we're going to
start making salmon,
you know,
if you could make one in one of those
in a little mixer, you know what I mean?
Take out your kitchen aid. Just get
that DNA swirling around in there.
You know?
That's what we should be doing.
We should be taking the DNA
of all of them just like a,
just like a in Jurassic Park where
they were running out of beat.
So I will fucking make some relax, you
know, custom order, how many you need.
Okay.
Oh, you let them loose. Just keep
making the bees so it, you know,
and then maybe they, they die a little
quicker. We just keep making, but then,
you know, whatever made the piece,
whatever that fucking machine was,
would cause even more global warming. I
think we're fucked. You know what I mean?
You know,
the more I think about that,
that's fucking lunatic that got everybody
to drink the fucking grape juice,
you know,
down there in South America.
I think he was onto something
that maybe he wasn't a nut.
Maybe he was just an environmentalist
and he was walking around a mall one day
and he was just like, you know what
you're saying? Right. You know,
and he went to a ball game. He's like,
yeah, you know, I'm still not feeling it.
You want the white neighborhoods, black
neighbor, Asian needs you, you know,
if you saw the people that you've
constraints to kill themselves.
Okay.
All colors, all creeds, all
ages. This guy, Dee Dee,
did a nice cleansing.
You know,
I'll tell you right now, you know,
next time, one of those guys who,
one of those Waco Texas guy goes a
little fucking sideways or you know,
they went live. See what happens.
Let's see where it goes with this.
All you gotta do is just surround them
and then he'll do the dirty work, right?
Hi Is, this is what you do. This is how
you solve the population problem, okay?
Instead of let nuts go on
the fucking street, you know,
you don't just take them out of the insane
asylum because you don't want to pay
for them anymore. What you do as
you get him a suit, all right?
And I don't know, you get them to start
a religion or something. I don't know.
I don't know what to do. Okay. As far
as I can, I can know what this plant is.
You'd let people out of insane asylums
and he'd give them a brand new suit and
like a briefcase, maybe like an
iPad or some shit like that. Right.
And then they get a fucking job.
And uh, well, you know what,
let's just start over again.
Good.
Looking and saint people regular
in saint people, you just,
you just put them out on the street the
way that we do. You know what I mean?
And then he'd get mad going, why is this
fucking asshole not obeying the, the,
the Jay walking in the street,
he go, oh my God, they're nuts.
They're fucking crazy. You know?
You know, look at that fucking,
if a person's out of the fucking mine
and you're literally in your car talking
to yourself too, and he's
not thinking it, you know,
is that how I'm going to end up?
I mean,
I might can be that person
just talking to myself,
doing that violent head
shake every fucking 10 feet,
walking up the street with a cart
full of God knows what deal is.
A Guy who sleeps on the sidewalk, um,
it's fucking like, I was going to say,
it's fucking, it's fucking hilarious
that his face is so wind burned.
Every time I look at them, it's like,
wow, the giants finally fired Tom Claflin.
And evidently he was not smart
with his money. Sorry. Whatever.
The Guy, he fucking leap
booze. Is it up? You know,
so it's a way to sync because you go
down there and my dog always looks at it,
the dude with like this,
but then there's concerned,
I get Doug knows when somebody is not a
threat and is actually in trouble. So I,
I've tried to talk to the person,
but it never seems to work out.
They just sort of looks at me like I
always feel like I'm freaking him out
because he's sleeping on the street. Like
I went, he thinks I'm gonna rob them, uh,
do something bad.
But what kills me about the Guy,
he always sleeps on the same side.
He sleeps on his left side right
on his fucking shoulder. Okay.
And what kills me is his head
never touches the ground.
He doesn't have a pillow. His head just
goes straight out. You know what I mean?
Like he got knocked out,
you know,
like we see a wide receiver
getting knocked down.
His fucking arms are sticking up. That's
what he looks like, but with his head,
and, uh, I always take how
sore his fucking neck is.
So I'm thinking about
getting him a pillow,
but I never know when
he's going to be there.
And I'm not going to walk my dog carrying
a fucking pill every day waiting to
see this guy.
And you know,
for all I know I'm going to
come walking up with a pillow.
He's going to think that I'm going
to try to smother them. Well,
maybe he's too crazy to accept the pill.
He starts eating it.
Chokes on the fucking feathers. I don't
know. But that's good for the bees.
So that's good for the bees. All
right. And I don't mean the Bruins,
right?
Maybe it's still positive way to look at
the future as more and more people get
fucking, you know, you just
started looking at it. It's
a good thing, you know,
didn't Carl and talk about shit like that?
That guy was so fucking far ahead of
his time. I think he talked about that.
And like the nineties like a joint
disasters rooting for him to happen.
You know,
it's weird enough that I think that way
when you actually have a kid that's,
that's, you know, that's a whole
other level of fucked up that I,
that I actually have to respect on some
level. Is that a half hour, 32 minutes?
I right.
I did it.
Okay.
Jesus Christ. And now,
right now it's 91 88 Boston,
there's only two minutes. 32
seconds left. So an NBA time,
it's at least 45 minutes over to the
white guy from at first light up.
There you go.
Black.
I points that I'm like finally
should have like 20 more assist you.
Bearded fuck. 'Em All right.
That's the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday, a Monday morning
podcast yet checking in on, you know,
if you guys have been a nice holiday
season, you get the time to uh,
and out with your friends.
And uh,
even though they don't advertise with
me anymore because I brought up the
possibly they could have sex
offenders driving their cars,
I think that was the final nail
in that advertising coffin. Um,
they are a great thing. You know, you
know what's great. If you had called it,
get there at two seconds
and then you can go out.
You can get blind drunk at a Christmas
party. Hit on your boss's wife, fair dies.
Say something fucked up to the chicken,
accounting it and call it a night and
not kill anybody and actually live long
enough to get reprimanded on Monday.
You know,
actually, I bet bees don't like
Uber. Do they? Oh, look at, Hey,
I'm Alexis Uber when you think about
it. All right, go fuck yourselves.
I have a wonderful weekend and
I'll talk to you on Monday,
okay?
Okay. Now tipsy elves. Everyone, you know,
everyone needs an ugly Christmas
sweater this time of year.
If you want bragging rights for the most.
Talked about sweater,
your Christmas party.
Listen Up.
Uh,
this is like some hipster Shit,
Huh?
Did you see these guys on shark tank a
couple of weeks ago with their latest
updates?
Everyone's talking about tips,
you gals and once they're outrageous
Christmas sweaters, everyone,
uh, talk about your tip. I
don't have a tipsy up sweater.
Trust me when I tell you these
tipsy elves Christmas sweaters.
I like nothing you've seen before and
they're not for the faint of heart.
Nobody's worn these ugly sweaters
before so you don't have to worry about
finding your size.
Okay?
MMM.
And you have,
they have a ton of styles to choose
from when you're shopping for your ugly
sweater,
checkout the holiday and collegiate tire
for yourself or is it gift like adult
onesies?
Right now my listeners get 20% off tipsy
elves.com or anything else in the site.
So go, uh, go to the dam site right now.
You have the best selection to choose
from and haven't in time for your ugly
Christmas sweater party.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and on my code
[inaudible] at checkout to get your 20%
off sitewide discount.
That's tipsy elves.com and my code burr.
Okay, here we go. Then,
oh look who's back.
[inaudible] me undies
software as it fucking goes,
but do, do, do me undies he undies
dip. You're not seeing this. No.
They'll get dried off nice and quick.
Don't forget about your fucking Dick
when you got me undies up against your
under carriage and made you feel
like a queen. Oh yeah. Okay. Me,
Andy's, we all had know
how sexy confidence can be.
And that's because confidence
comes from being comfortable.
But our great can you feel in
your underwear is wrinkling
and riding up on your
fucking balls.
There me undies gets it.
They have balls and they like them to
hang free or at least be massaged me
undies gets it.
And that's why they created the world's
most comfortable underwear for a daily
dose of cons. For confidence.
You wear underwear every day.
Unless you're Matthew mcconaughey,
that's 365 days a year. Rain or shine.
So you know what?
You needed it to be an IX.
You need it to be extraordinary without
an insane price. Tag me, he's young,
he's understands this.
We get it. We get it.
That you get it through and that's why
they've created, you just said this shit.
Uh, when you look good, you feel great.
It's a cliche because it's true. Uh,
beyond these understands this. Once
again, they understand, they understand.
A lot of shit,
and that's why they've
discovered underwear that
makes you look good and feel
fantastic.
Uh,
note Medallia's pronounced modelle
modal beyond these is made from modal,
my grandma, the Alma mobile mobile of
ferric. That's twice as soft as cotton.
That's twice the softest. Whatever's
up against your balls right now,
unless you're wearing me on these
beyond says tons of different colors and
styles and the only place to get
matching pairs from men and women.
Plus he whipped, they even
release a new design every month.
I wear whatever free ones they give me
a god damn on my balls have never felt
better. Plus we all know that
paying for shipping sucks,
so me undies was nice enough to roll it
into the price and say that there isn't
any in us or Canada.
Me undies even has a money back guarantee.
If you don't love your first pair,
you got to keep it for free.
You literally have nothing to lose.
To sweeten the deal.
Me undies is offering you 20% off your
first order at [inaudible] dot com slash
bar that's a special order for just
my listeners or where whatever else,
whatever other podcasts
they are the a advertise on.
Make sure to go to [inaudible] dot com
slash bird he get 20% off your first
order and so that know, they know that we
said, you know what, they they left down.
It makes it great.
Stockings stop. All right.
Lastly, but not leastly zip
recruiter. As a business owner,
your company is only as good as the
people you hire posting jobs in one place.
Well, that's not enough to
find quality candidates.
Now is it short staffing leaves little
time to post a dozens of job sites for
Christ's sake. When it be great,
if you could just go to one place,
well now you can't.
Ziprecruiter, Ziprecruiter,
you can post a 100 plus job
sites with one single click.
Be instantly matched to candidates from
over 6 million resumes plus watch brand
new candidates roll into ZipRecruiter's,
easy to use interface within 24 hours.
Ziprecruiter has been used by over
400,000 businesses a today. You can try
ZipRecruiter for free.
Go to ziprecruiter.com/bird
that's ziprecruiter.com/burr ha,
ziprecruiter.com/bar
[inaudible]
a belt. I look forward to it. Everyone.
All right.
It
gets me Jesus Christ with it. Okay. I
want to ask you some questions. Ask it.
I'm 25 years old and had been married
for two years to a great woman.
No kids yet. Uh, we live very close to
all of her family, parents, grandparents,
cousins, all of them. Oh
Jesus. Yeah, absolutely. That
can be a fucking nightmare.
All right. You better. You better
have the ground rules down. All right.
It'd be like, listen, I know your family
fucking lives right around the corner,
but this is my fucking house.
All right?
It's my fucking house.
They only come around on the holidays
for not just show up
like Kramer on Seinfeld.
It's nothing to be be none of that 20th.
Anyways,
her is planning this big three day
long family reunion this summer.
And as much as I love my wife,
I would rather take a shit on a hooker's
toilet then go to this thing. Yeah,
absolutely. Dude, you surrounded by them.
I spend far too much time with their
family as it is. And worst of all,
I think it might conflict with when
you come to do a show in my hometown,
I told her today that have for you reunion
is the same weekend that you come to
town. That I will just have to
skip the reunion. Good man. Uh,
she let me have it for about
how important it is to her.
This is what they do.
This is what they do. Um,
how her family comes first.
And if I was a good person,
I would go to the reunion and
then she started to cry. Oh Dude,
she hit you with both
barrels, both barrels. Dude,
this is all fucked up.
I'm actually going to whisper in,
my lovely woman is fucking four states
away. I had this fucking argument.
I had this argument fucking
a week ago. All right. Uh,
oh my God,
he got to get to the post.
You got to get to the mailbox first
and look for those fucking wedding
invitations,
all right?
And you get that and you just rip it
up and fire it over the fucking fence.
All right. I didn't do
that. All right. I saw it.
I knew it was an invitation is she
gets his fucking invitation to go to a
goddamn wedding.
Okay?
All right. In the middle of
fucking nowhere. All right.
And I said, I'm not going. I'm not going.
And then she starts telling
me how important these people
are to her. And I said,
give me a fucking break.
They're important to you.
I've never heard you say their names.
I don't even recognize these names.
How can this be important?
How can they, and then she,
and then she starts faith.
She just did the exact fucking same thing.
Short of the crime,
you know,
I would think that you would want to go
with this to me is important and blah,
blah, blah. It's like, sweetheart, I
spend my life in airports, on airplanes.
I don't want to go to one
extra fucking thing. Okay.
Tell him to put it on Skype and I'll
sit there and watch it with you.
I don't want to fucking go to it.
Right.
Let me ask you to do we
ask them to go to any shit.
Like I would never drag my
girl to a football game. She
hates it. But I sit there.
This is really important to me.
Then you are a good person.
You go until gang get truck with me.
It's fucking ridiculous.
I don't want to go.
So anyways,
and then she started to cry.
He said,
I have got a lot of a lot of this
shit since they got married. Yeah,
I could tell you that too. Cause
you're 25, you know, you're 25.
If you're 25,
when you get fucking married,
a woman is going to be 10 years beyond
you just knowing how to fucking roll over
you in a relationship. But not
all is not lost. All is not lost.
Let me finish this. Um, if
anything happens in her family,
I have to be there.
Even if it's as small as their cousin
graduating from the third grade.
I'm sick of it. I mean, I really
hate doing stuff like this.
She knows I don't like it, but if I
was just a flat out teller, I hate it.
It would break her heart. All
right, so you're a decent guy. Okay.
I would hate to do that because she's my
wife and I love her. All right. See you.
Good guy. Thinking about her. Okay. Oh,
and I see my family and I see my family
about once a year since they live on the
other side of the country.
She just doesn't understand that I did
not grow up in a family where we spend a
ton of time together. So Shit, shit, life,
family reunions, uh, doesn't
mean that much to me.
I feel like those ladies should understand
that if I miss one weekend with them
to see my favorite comedian who I might
not get a chance to see again in a very
long time,
then that's all right.
How do I let her know how I feel and get
to give me some space and not crush my
balls about going to all of her
family stuff. Um, all right. Do,
this is what you do. Your head, your
heart, your heart's in the right place.
You don't want to hurt her,
okay?
Okay.
And I'm going to kind of side with
your wife on this one in that,
not really sagging with her, but you pick
the wrong one to put your foot down on.
All right? What she had to do is
put your foot down on, you know,
little Mikey just made his first
fucking popsicle stick house.
We all have to go over and look at it.
That's something that you could blow off,
like a major family reunion.
You kinda got to go to that.
You gotta be by his side. Okay?
So that she can prove that. See,
I got one. He loves me. Right? So this
is what you, what you are right now,
you're in a great position to barter,
okay?
Because you're going to make the
sacrifice and not seeing my shell.
Okay? So this is what you
tell him. Just say, listen,
my favorite comedian is coming to town.
Just like you said,
I might not get another chance to see him,
but because this is so important to you,
I want to be there for you. So I will go.
Okay. And she'll say, great, thank
you. And then you say however.
Okay.
All right. This is when you
barter and just say all this.
I don't know how to say this eloquently
cause I just have to get to the point.
All this fucking bullshit. These conti
little stupid ass fucking things.
I don't give a fuck about you. I
don't want to go to him anymore. Okay.
I work all day. I come home. I want to
chill out. I don't know your family.
I don't know. I married you.
Okay. You want to go to the,
you know the Oscars or your family
reunion. I will go to that shit. Okay.
You dad gets a new colostomy bag.
I'm not showing up to that.
I am not going to all of them.
I will go to some major ones.
I will go to Christmas time.
I'll put on the sweater.
Alright,
but this fucking 24 seven
all the fucking time Susie.
Fuck face is having a birthday party.
I'm not going to it.
I'm staying home and I'm
watching the game. Okay.
Because it's making me miserable and I
want to be happy with you. All right?
And this is the thing, she might give
you shit about that, but no, you got it.
You got to put your foot down and
let her cry about it. All right.
And just say this isn't fair to me.
This isn't fair to me,
that all of my free time
involves being with your family.
All right? I don't know
how you say it, dude.
You got to figure out how
to say it's fucking boring.
Good Lord going over there.
I don't like the smell of their house.
I don't like their food.
I don't like the color of their plates.
I just want to get the fuck out of there.
I'm not comfortable.
You are go over there.
They're prompt.
They probably don't even
like you go on over there.
You know they want their girl over
there so fucking go over there.
So that's what I would do.
Um, just, just play game.
All right? My show is important to you,
is that fucking thing. So why don't you,
why don't you cry? No, I can't do
that. But you know what I'm saying?
Just flip it around and just
be like, all right, well,
I want you to know that I'm missing my
favorite fucking comedian to go to this
thing. Okay? And I will go to this
thing, okay? But from here on out,
I am only going to the major ones,
okay? Because I love you. I support you.
But this ticky tack fucking Horse
Shit. That's all you. I'm not,
I'm not doing that,
okay?
Because I need a life outside of this,
outside of your family.
All right? Go for it. Self love you.
Love you buttons. I'll see you
later. How's that? Does that work?
They're built.
Well, I met you after show in Pittsburgh,
the black guy with the hot. Let Tina,
we laughed about my shoes,
matching my outfit.
Well,
my beautiful girlfriend for the past
three years as a little bit of insecurity,
insecurity issues. Uh, a lot of
those are absolutely gorgeous women.
Do you know why it is?
It's because their level
without even reading this shit,
the reason why I think a lot of them
are fucking insecure is because,
because of beautiful and
that goes away after a while.
So the clock is just fucking ticking.
You know,
if you would just some
regular douche bag like me,
there's no pressure going back to
your fucking high school reunion.
I mean the expectations is so fucking low,
you know,
it's easy to just surpass him. Like, oh
Geez, he didn't get fat. Sky's awesome.
But if you're a fucking hot chick, it
could just, it could only go downhill.
And I also think that they have the same
insecurity a rich guy has what a rich
guys like. This woman's just
with me because of my money,
not because of who I am.
I think that they have the insecurity.
This person is just with me
because of my ass today. Hayes.
Hi. All right. For summary. Odd Reason.
She feels the need for me to prove to
her that I love her whenever we're in a
public setting. So recently
during some Christmas shopping,
uh, she got upset that I wouldn't hold
her hand as we walked through the mall.
She proceeded to catch one of the,
one of her spicy Latin attitudes with me.
Um, see now if you were white and you
said that, and you said that on TV,
you would have to apologize for
nine weeks when you lose your job,
why does it have to be spicy? Are
you saying that lat to, you know,
people are like their
peppers. Um, all right,
I'm gonna stop commenting and just
plow through this. Okay. So I handle,
handle the situation like a g parenthesis
gentlemen and completely ignored her
ass, um, until we got into the car.
And I finally had enough of her telling
me how I don't love her and how she
wants me to love her.
Oh, I don't love her.
How she wants me to love her and
are unaffected unit of a man. I am.
And you know what,
dude?
That right there is probably how you got
this hot girl because you weren't the
first guy. He's sitting there with
your tongue hanging out of your mouth.
You acted like you
didn't even give a fuck,
which fed into her and security of like,
oh my God, is the expiration date hit?
Am I not hot anymore? Um, look at
me commenting again. All right.
I swear these bitches
are so unappreciative.
Unappreciative as, it's funny.
You call them pictures.
What?
Can't these bitches understand how much I
appreciate this. Uh, every weekend bill,
we do something, dinner,
movies, plays, et Cetera.
But because she has a vantage, she has
to find something to complain about.
I think it's because women have this
trait where they feel a strong need to be
miserable. No, dude, you know what's
going on is you're spoiling her.
You're taking her to dinner. Movies
plays every fucking weekend. She,
now she's come to expect it.
You know what I mean?
It's just become part of a routine.
It's not special anymore.
So now you have to do something extra
special. Cause special. Is it special?
You know, that's what I, I, you know
what? I'm gonna have to whisper this shit.
We were up in San Francisco, right? I
lit up. My credit card says Christmas.
All right. My girl had a
great fucking Christmas. All
right, it's three days later,
we're up in fucking San Francisco. She
wants to go shopping. I'm like, for what?
You didn't get enough, you know, so she
knows him. Right? So what does she do?
She tells me she wants a goddamned
candle. Okay. Because it's not expensive,
but she'll still feel like she got
something because I don't know what it is.
They always get a fee.
They always got to get stuff is there.
He's got to be some sort of a goody bag.
And you know what? I wouldn't get it for,
I wouldn't get it for like a,
you'd done? No, I'm not. It's over.
My credit cards are still glowing. I'm
not getting you shit. And you know,
she's cool as hell.
So she just kept laughing because I was
being unbelievably rude and I was being
really loud. I was just joking
around and uh, but still,
that's the thing. And I just kept
saying, I spoil you. Um, you know,
we're shutting it down for a while.
You're not getting anything
until Valentine's Day. You know,
you want something now I'll
get you a little bag of Fritos.
What do you think about death?
Maybe something to wash it down with.
And then what they do is they immediately
get mad and then all you do is you
don't take the bait.
They want you to get mad.
So then they can turn it into a fight
about something else because they know
you're fucking right. All
right? So let it be met.
All you gotta do what? You just
got to stay fucking comp. Well,
let's see what this guy does.
Uh, so anyways, he goes,
so we are driving along the highway,
leaving the mall and she's still bitching.
And finally I tell, uh, you know what,
if you don't like the way I express
my love for you, then step off, uh,
got to read that quote like a black man.
I can't, I'm not even going to try to, uh,
so immediately I actually read that.
I read that like a Douchey east coast
white guy. That fucking step off.
Uh,
how did you fuck off bitch?
I was at, was that good? I know it wasn't
well that don't ask me to do it. Alright,
plowing ahead. You know what? I might
have like a fucking substitute black guy.
Four black guys.
Write some shit in here so you guys can
read it the way you supposed to say it.
Other than that, you're getting
fucking a crack, harass, read,
and you're going to have to live with it.
All right?
So immediately after that I said,
after I said that this bitch starts
throwing these accurate and quick ass.
Paki Oh, combos. She's
punching you. Mind you,
I'm doing 65 miles per
hour down the highway,
trying not to hit the guardrail while at
the same time getting this crazy bitch
off me.
Luckily I didn't crash
my year old Mercedes.
This guy's hilarious. Come on
dude. Do you love this girl?
She just another accessory.
Um,
my year old Mercedes with
the Corinthian leather, uh,
I get pulled over, I get pulled over
or God forbid, seriously injure us.
I mushed the hell out of her and held
her face against the passenger window.
Totally acceptable. Totally.
The Mush is the gentleman move.
You can't punch her. You just hold their
head up against the glass, you know,
so the people on the other side gets to
see what her face looks at a fun House
Mirror
in order to decrease her reach while
steering the car on the highway and
absorbing her manly combos. Got to
give it to her. The bitch had a mean.
Right. Um, so if you
can picture me driving,
I can totally picture this
dude. I've lived this. Um,
so you can picture me driving down the
highway in a bright red Mercedes. Okay.
Not, I didn't have a, had a Mercedes.
It was more than a 83 Ford
ranger with black vinyl seats.
Swerving like some drunk
in and out of lanes,
steering with one hand and stiff arming
the shit out of my girls if I'm posing
for the Heisman trophy.
After she stopped beating my face in,
she had the nerve to say I hit her.
It hurt her worse by pressing
her face against the glass.
Are you fucking kidding me?
This bitch took both of our lives.
Long story short. As soon as I was able
to come to a safe and complete stop,
I kicked a bitch out and haven't heard
from her since. This was three weeks ago,
and it's all for the best.
That type of girl can never be satisfied,
which is something I've learned the
hard way over the past three years.
But this was the straw that did it.
So my question for you is,
was I wrong in this situation
and do I owe her an apology?
No and no.
All right?
All you can do is break down
your game plan. All right?
This is where you fucked up.
You took the bait, all right?
She kept pitching and pitching
and pitching and pitching,
trying to make you mad.
She was torn. She got you to do
exactly what she wanted you to do.
So that gave her an a,
an excuse to do what she wanted to do,
which was fucking flip out and yell,
all right?
That's what they do when they know they
don't have a fucking leg to stand on and
they know they're wrong. What
they then try to do, you know,
not all of them and
not in every situation,
but when then they're not going to be
an adult and just say, you know what?
You're right. I'm being fucking
crazy right now. I apologize. Okay.
When they're not going
to take that adult route,
what they then do is they just push your
buttons and they just try to make you
mad and they just keep pushing you and
pushing it and pushing it and pushing it
until you then flip out and say
something fucking crazy like, well,
if you don't like it, then why don't you
get the fuck out? And then they flip out.
All right?
So what you got to do is in the future
is you just don't take the bait.
You've got to recognize,
you know they're doing,
they're doing the fucking
Dennis Rodman thing to you,
the Beighton you into a penalty.
That's all they're doing. Okay.
And the ref always sees the retaliation.
That's basically,
it's the same fucking thing.
So when the future just don't get mad,
it will drive them up the fucking wall
and you won't believe the amount of
argument she can to start winning
because in their effort to piss you off,
they're going to cross like
10 of the lights. All right?
Now when they cross 10 other lines,
if you take the bait and then
go even further down the road,
that's all that's remembered in the end.
As you then try and piece together
who said what when, but if they go,
if they cross 10 lines and
you don't take the bait,
they attend lines beyond where the fuck
they should be and you got him dead to
rights and you just have to
maintain your fucking cool.
Now getting back to this other shit
is you do not own her fucking apology.
All right?
It's absolutely fucking ridiculous.
It's absolutely childish and you can't
as an adult expect somebody to not hit
you if you're hitting them all right?
She's basically asking you to,
we can extend a common human to human
courtesy that she's not extending to you
so she can go fuck herself.
You definitely,
I don't know if you made the right move.
I don't know if you walk around calling
her a bitch and that type of thing.
This is you just trying to
be a tough guy going in.
This bitch said this and this, you
know, this bitch said that. Uh,
that's another thing. Don't go around
calling a bitches cause that Dee Dee,
that just kills your og. Don't have
a call of bad names. All right?
Just hold your ground.
Don't lose your fucking cool and let them
go through their whole little fucking
history. Onyx trying to get you to
take the fucking bait. All right?
And as long as in the relationship,
you admit when you're wrong
and you sincerely apologize,
they don't have a fucking leg to stand
on when you're right and you're going to
start winning arguments and you're going
to be happier. There you go. Alright.
And other than that, I
dunno. Stopped dating site.
Take it easy
for the break of day
that swim up the window
crying. It won't do no good. Oh,
come back.
Hi Vic.
How to help myself.
I won't mistreat chew.
We have no one now
tell me Barry,
but once you're trying to do,
I didn't have a fucking party
for a new place. You don't.
You think that was my idea.
Do you think it was my idea to have a
bunch of strangers come into the fucking
house? I'll have people
over. That's what I do. Hey,
you want to come over and watch the
game? Nine people that I know, right?
Have all your fucking phone numbers.
You don't. Nia is a more open person.
So she's like, let's tell him a party.
All right, so we still, she goes,
invite your friends. So I'm
all right. So you know I got,
you know, I'm a, I'm a guy,
I don't have a bunch of friends.
Okay.
I got six good friends for that I could
really trust, you know, it's about it,
at least out here.
Then over here in Nia,
talking to her mom about all excited
about the party and she's like, yeah,
I sent it on a Facebook and
I was just like, oh my God,
did I just invite 110 people?
And my heart literally sank going,
please tell me you didn't just invite
110 fucking people. She's like,
don't worry, they're not all
going to show up. It's like, yeah,
but like a third wheel.
And then they're going to bring people
that you don't even fucking know.
And that's exactly what happened.
It was a fucking great party.
I'm not going to lie to you,
but I got to admit like I
got to learn how to and be.
I thought I was going to be a good host.
I was and I wasn't.
I was all right with the people I
knew. But the people I didn't know, uh,
they actually, most of them are all
right, but there were a couple of them.
I just find it just sends you something
fucking annoying about somebody you
don't know. Sitting on your
God damn couch, you know,
eating your food, drinking your booze.
He like Hula Food of fuck are you,
it's somebody else was laying down on
the floor. I felt like the kids' Dad,
I want to make, get them get a
fucking job, right? It's over.
You're 26 she fucking pump. So
anyways, so the party is going great.
And uh, I'm basically the whole time,
you know, not drink it too much,
but I'm standing by the front door
cause that's the only way up. All right?
And nobody's walking out
with any of my shit, right?
I'm acting basically like psycho
in fucking stripes. It's how I am.
It's how I'm wired.
All right?
So a fucking three quarters
the way through the party,
everything's going great.
And I'm like, wow, this is
I, you know what? I forgot.
I forgot. I'm not 21 anymore.
I'm fucking 43.
All my friends are adults and everybody's
drinking responsibly and no one's
really hammered. Nothing got
broken, everything's cool.
So start just as I was starting to relax,
some kid comes up to me, he's like, Eh,
Eh, you own the house. And I'm
like, well, the bank owns it.
I'm fucking painted it off. What
can I do for you? And he's like, uh,
yeah, it's kind of embarrassing. But a,
I used the bathroom downstairs and uh,
it's clogged now.
And I was wondering if he had a plunger.
And I was like, yeah, I do have a plunger.
I got a plunger right here, the upstairs
bathroom. So I give it to the guy and I,
and I say, man, I appreciate your honesty.
He goes, no problem. He goes downstairs,
he takes care of it, comes back,
he wants again. He goes, he goes,
sorry about that. I said, not at all, not
at all. What the fuck to toilet, you know,
clogs up every once in a while. But I
appreciate it. I appreciate your honesty.
You know, cause that would have been
nasty. Good for you. Right. So, uh,
now the couple of hours goes by,
the party ends and there's
like one straggler left. And
I tell the story to knee.
I'm like, yeah, I want to go. What a good
guy. What a good shit. No Pun intended.
You know,
he could have left it in there.
And then the other party I come walking
in my fucking bathroom looks like a
Goddamn Port Authority bus station,
toilet, you know, so I was psyched.
So, so one of the strategies of
the party goes, yeah, he goes,
I saw that whole thing go down.
That's not exactly how it went down.
Like what he talking
about. He goes, he goes,
it wasn't him that was in the bathroom.
And I go, who was it? He goes,
it was his girlfriend
some way,
took a dump of a magnitude that
it wouldn't go down the toilet.
So now she's in there panicking and this
is what today's technology kicks in.
She could back in the day,
she would have had to crawl out the
fucking window and hope nobody saw her and
just left the door locked. Everybody
would have panicked. Holy Fuck.
Who's in there? Did somebody pass out? If
somebody, if somebody committed suicide,
someone woulda kicked in the door,
alright,
knocked it off the fucking goddamn
hinges and you go in there,
that'd be nobody in there.
You'd feel the air from outside.
And then look down and everyone
would see a giant shit and be like,
as a party would be over and the owner
of the house would be walking around
going,
okay,
you better drive away. Right.
That's how it would have ended.
But because of today's technology,
not saying she didn't panic,
you know it's even worse.
There's a lady,
cause they're not even supposed
to do stuff like that. Right.
And she was able to text her boyfriend
and I would fucking pay at least $400 to
read those texts,
the panic in those texts.
And to his credit, he
fucking, he stepped it up.
He took the hit, he
came up to me, VH ones.
I love the eighties own Belper and said,
I took a dump when your toilet to
a magnitude, it didn't go down.
And I need the tools required
to alleviate this situation.
So Anti Douche bag of the week,
that guy right there.
So taking a fucking
bullet for the team that,
that right there is the
reverse Peyton manning award.
He didn't fucking go, we had protection
issue, right? No, he took one.
He took one for the fucking tape,
went upstairs like a Goddamn gentlemen
asked for a plunger, gave it to him,
and it was all fine. And I went
down there at the end of the party,
you never would've known anything,
anything happened. You know what I mean?
Like, uh, you know, three hours after
the Kennedy assassination. I bet it was.
It was all, I'm say it, you know,
marked it all up and everything was all
figured out it, but it was a nice road.
Again,
mopped up the brain.
What am I talking about?
[inaudible].